you all right
up
this
way
this then
out on your shoulder
keep it on your
shoulder my on my shoulder is moving it
the wrist and my double grips ring the
elbow
back inward
spiral into up here it is right
here but on the spiral
and add your
Mar it's not c a on okay you have a
outright break here
where you're at so I have to be
perpendicular my attack angle is
perpendicular to his elbow at the tricep
tendent of insertion this is what I'm
doing when I add the spiral it kind of
looks like katat but it doesn't feel
like it okay cuz
katak is going to roll the arm around
you see you want to bend so you're
rolling this way this one I don't want
want to bend I don't let him Bend I
don't let him roll it you see that I
don't want him doing that I'm countering
that with my arm and the
spiral by the time we're down here it's
too late okay it's too much pressure for
him to roll it you see I don't want
that so I'm here like this ear
controlling ear
controlling and I'm snapping
up into place don't roll it over attack
it right at the angle that it's at so
you can have your knee
[Music]
Stripes don't roll it
over keep it at the
[Music]
90 second
lane don't do this
only go
under see how low I get so I don't have
to lift my arm as
much they go under
this one's not a p try to understand
okay what I'm doing is getting the
ground to stabilize the
shoulder so you got him here as that's
what that move is you're not hanging out
here okay
you get you hit that shoulder it comes
back and now and now you're up and
moving okay so be dynamic don't have
your weight on your
heels okay
hold down like
that Bo down you smash his face on the
street and you have the break right
there okay so
you can't be static like we are here in
training but you can see a midfoot
weight not back here like this I'm right
here where all my core can just start
snapping that elbow and I can move
quickly
okay so have good midot
Vector where you get power but
Mobility okay TR right
so I don't always have to get
him uh so the ground won let him keep
absorbing that you see how much the
ground is not being pinned won't let me
get the other
stabilizing energy on this side so he
just goes down with it but you can see
how he's right at my right knee my left
knee okay so here I'm doing the same
thing boom throwing the knee
so we'll start there okay everything's
the same but I'm going to drop him into
that knee
okay
boom careful cuz he's coming towards me
and you're going for okay
[Music]
don't resist El like that
okay okay right
watch watch where I where you're going
to feel
okay
boom go under okay don't go this
way you see how it's rolling it f it it
goes this way you see that so if I don't
move my feet you have to take your Camy
where do you want to
go you
think other one I don't move my feet
elbow rolls
forward so my hand doesn't go this way
my hand goes this way now the elbow's
lock you see and then I move
that and take it into me
boom okay try it again okay we go slow
first everything's the
same boom on into my KNE boom I'm going
to keep it you see I'm going to keep it
going that way and add my tens no no
no we're going to go this
way
okay there's
my into the leg then I'm going to throw
him this
way okay
boom I'm going to throw him this way
stay still I'm show it without the break
he's going that way
okay H take it this way
[Music]
I start adding my movement
that do this
way we're going to roll around the other
side of that elbow but it's still lock
in
place boom it's right here
so we know this technique
right I'm doing it all from the
elbow Sensei I got your back that's se
you
ball kick
[Music]
right okay if we're going to throw
someone under us we have to have a
counter okay
try Okay boom this hand right here this
hand's going to push you see he's going
this way there it
is boom boom a into the knee HP this
hand right here
push okay so now now that you know what
the elbow is doing okay try not to open
it up that much boom so all I got to do
is roll onto this side see that see that
knife edge there so originally I'm using
the forearm bone
but look where this Palm heel knife edge
is it's right there where you were doing
that you see that you guys understand so
you come back
up here I'm using this forearm bone to
bring him into the other knee well the
knife edge is right in place so that is
where you were doing that and I'm just
going to do it with my knife edge right
this
way and then I didn't have to open that
up at all okay
forarm bone
okay
boom then other hand you want to go this
way you
can this
way this
way in back
or on the other
side put your chin back I'm going to go
one two and
through okay all
right all right so uh when you're here
this is that move right there okay but
look how high he is you see he's that
high so when I do the other move he's
going to get
lower see his
head so even your hair you're going slow
and smooth okay he coming around take
note of where his head
is this head should not come back up on
this
movement should not do
this it should go lower
boom see and it goes lower the whole
time notop back up
okay keep your P mentality
going Boomin mentality down see
boom also note how
I'm going to start to control this arm
where the New Path of
action see
Boom
[Music]
Out
TR okay so as I'm moving
On Pop I monitor his head he's going to
go down I'm going to keep control of the
arms you see keep control of the arm I
do that same stomp kick but instead of
passing through with his arm here it's
boom and kick it out and now it's not in
between your
BL keep his head low C boom kick it out
and you're out okay so just like the the
first drill I came here right we took it
down and I have so much power here okay
cuz I'm by mechanically
sound turn
over same thing I'm not going to throw
it to his face I'll just lightly just a
little you see
that is but it's going boom
okay here's your
arm it's not
this here boom you see the
difference so you can show it slow
coom but it's full with good body
mechanics see where I am and I'm
out I'm not leaning over
here have good body mechanics boom and
boom out okay